ABCs of AI e is for explainable ai
explainable ai is a set of tools and
Frameworks that help humans analyze and
understand the results provided by ml
models it's kind of like if you're able
to ask this technology wait how did we
get here and then it just tells you with
explainable AI you can debug and improve
model performance and help others
understand your model's Behavior based
on the data features the algorithm used
and the environment of the model in
question and fun fact it's natively
integrated with a number of Google's
products and services check out some
other cool stuff related to explainable
AI in the links below and what else do
you want to know more about on the next
episode of